overbearing in I want to go
so you can afford it
I got it yes yes listen there's good
news first of all you're 20 you're a
baby yes you're crazy you're wrong
you're wrong you're 20 which means you
have 80 years to live 80 right number
two you're in America like you your
future
you're listening to the wrong voices
you're looking you're looking at what's
in front of you right now
college doesn't mean [ __ ] college
doesn't mean [ __ ] so I don't give a [ __ ]
that you dropped out of college I think
it's good that you dropped out of
college you need to if you think your
life is [ __ ] your life is [ __ ] keep
listening to more of my content you need
[ __ ] positivity coming through your
ears when [ __ ] all that negativities
come in your head put your [ __ ]
headphones in and listen to positivity
and go get a job and start saving money
[Music]
okay I understand here
listen this there's always gonna be
tough times there's always gonna be
comebacks
it's just a little part of your life
it's this is only a couple years of your
life one year two years three years it's
a small part of your money you're gonna
be 25 one day you're gonna be 30 one day
they're gonna be 35 one day her [ __ ]
baby everything can go wrong for the
next six years everything and you'll
still be a baby
that's real it doesn't feel real when
you're 20 but it's [ __ ] real that's
the truth and once you understand that
all of a sudden you can start taking the
baby steps to [ __ ] do something good
positivity in your ears not just me
whatever I don't care
music or whatever but put positivity in
your ears that negativity that you're
hearing you got to get that the [ __ ] out
of your life if you can't move out yet
put [ __ ] in your ears you walk in put
the [ __ ] headphones on in your house
close your door and [ __ ] listen
that's the game
you're welcome
there we go listen
you're ensuring control not your medical
tradition not your parents not America
not immigration
you're in control that's the truth
[Music]